on irony and that means the game against  aneesh giri is done and it's a win for  anish giri he wins his first match in  the ftx crypto cup winning two games  against hans niemann and he's still  sitting inside the arena anishkiri is he  just  enjoying his play in this game was a  good win by anish uh he doesn't look too  happy with because actually  but uh yeah he's a student of the game  that's why he shaking his head there but  that's why everyone loves him that's why  he's known as an opening expert he  studies so hard works on his chest  incredibly so he's just looking where he  could have improved just checking with  the computer there and i'm sure we'll  hear his thoughts but a win is a win  he's got to take it and his luck has  turned he's been unlucky so far today  was different